-So, uh, John Cena --
-Mm-hmm.
-There's a scene that's
getting a lot of attention,
and this is you
and the other two parents.
But can you explain what
exactly John is doing here?
-I know, that makes it look
even worse
than what actually happened.
-Yeah.
Because Ike here seems to be
pouring beer into a funnel.
-So it's a --
it's a thing called, um...
Well, I guess that's
the name of it,
but buttchugging...
-Buttchugging.
-...is what we call it.
But it's a beer bong,
but through your, um...
-Your butt, yeah.
-Your south mouth.
That's what John Cena calls it.
[ Laughter ]
And so -- don't do this,
though.
That's not -- it's not safe
to do, obviously.
-The good news is I don't think
anyone was thinking
they were going to run out.
It's like, it's not like
you're making it look fun.
Look at John Cena's face.
-I know.
It's so --
-But does this --
his pants were off,
right, on set?
-Okay, so he has, um...
I'm, you know, want to be
sensitive about him.
He loves being naked,
by the way.
He's, like, very comfortable.
He works out
obviously all the time.
-Yeah. He's -- yeah.
-And, um...
but he has this, um...
His -- you know, like --
So anyway, he had to, like,
bend over
without pants on
to shoot this scene
for hours, and, um --
And I was trying to, you know,
block him with my skirt
because there were,
like, 100 extras behind.
-You had tons of extras
back there, yeah.
-And he's like, "It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine."
And he had nothing covering
his butt.
So I, you know,
just a quick sneak peek, just...
[ Laughter ]
And, like, a normal butt is --
there's not like...
you know, there's not, like --
there's -- there's not
a lot of space
between the outside
and what it's covering.
-Yeah.
-So, like, when it moves
around like mine,
you can see what --
-You can see other parts.
-You could see that area.
-Yeah.
-His butt,
it's like two giant --
there's like four inches
from the outside to...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It's like four inches,
so even if he's bent over,
you can't see anything,
so that's --
He's like, "I don't care."
[ Laughter ]
"It's fine."
And, so, it was -- yeah, he was
super comfortable doing that.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You -- that was -- I found out
so much more about John Cena.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-You, uh...you have
two teenage daughters.
-Yes.
-And they saw the premiere
at South by Southwest.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you saw it
with your whole family.
Judd was there as well?
-Yeah, uh-huh.
-And what was their review?
What did they think of the film?
-They, uh...my --
they loved it so much.
And we were driving home
in the car afterward.
And first of all,
I've never, like --
people were laughing harder
than I've ever heard.
Like, it really -- it was, like,
a really fun experience for me.
It was really fun to, you know,
hear everybody be so happy
and love the movie so much.
But we were in the car afterward
and Maude said,
"That was the funniest movie
I have ever seen.
I have never laughed that hard
in a movie ever."
And Judd was in the front seat,
and he's like...
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, well, 'Trainwreck' --
"'Trainwreck' played
pretty well there, too,
at South by Southwest.
It was good, too."
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, so that --
yeah, but it's great.
-Well, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's always such
a delight to see you, Leslie.